back to my great friend Thomas Mann this
Sheila lecture which I quoted in the
beginning at the end of it he he said
with Sheila you know artists the
educator of mankind artist educator of
mankind you will agree with him
definitely yes okay but but explain to
us why art is you know why is it you
make such a movie and you know it isn't
an initiator of a lot of change on many
levels first of all art creates or
ignites empathy I think the the fact
that you know it humanizes a problem I
decided in this film to just understand
of course you hear about this problem on
the news you hear about it from someone
you might live it from closely or you
might the fact that I live in a place
where lots of things are not going the
way they should the fact that you know I
encountered children on the street every
day of my life children begging children
working children being abused children
not going to school children hungry
children sleeping on the streets and and
of course when you encounter such
injustice you feel I personally felt if
I was going to stay silent I was
collaborating in this crime I cannot as
a human being adapt to the situation I
cannot keep living as if this was not
happening in my life so I just decided
to use my tool which is art to use it as
a magnifying glass and just humanize the
problem lots of people hear about this
but you hear about it in statistics and
number it can actually humanize it it
actually can put a face on the struggle
art in that way
opens the door invites you in to just
emphasize with another human being to
understand what really goes on and when
you start identifying and emphasizing
it's not another human being anymore
it's also something that concerns you
you don't look at it as someone else you
just identify with it and you start
seeing the problem from your perspective
and maybe you would start thinking what
if I was in that situation how would I
react the idea of great books has come
under challenge in large part because it
doesn't represent the great variety and
diversity of stories out there one of
the unfortunate consequences is that
there's sort of an almost wholesale
replacement of those books that rather
than read them and maybe read them more
critically there's a replacement with
more contemporary work that while I
think it's valuable isn't you know it
doesn't mean that the other older books
need to be crowded out
and that also some of them were content
rather than sort of go back to other
cultures and look for classics within
those cultures a lot of the books that
are currently being assigned and I'm
talking about it the sort of secondary
school level tend to be very
contemporary works that are don't even
necessarily represent the best of every
culture and I think are more towards
making sure that people feel like their
experiences are reflected in what
they're reading if you go back to what
you said about the function of art and
of literature is to foster empathy I
think that it's all the more important
that we read from traditions outside of
our own culture so there's something to
be commended for that in terms of these
new votes but the same could be said for
the classics that you could should
continue to go back and to because if it
doesn't reflect the culture if those
books don't reflect the culture of the
current diversity in American schools
then all the more important than to know
them and to be able to criticize them or
to look at them critically before you
just say okay well let's get
rid of it all together in America now
you can defend the humanities but only
on economic grounds so a theater
improves a neighborhood or many people
who study English become McKinsey
consultants but the fact is that you do
it for itself intrinsically and you do
it for the cultivation of the person and
the cultivation of the citizen which
should be reward enough the idea of
educating citizens for the sake of
educating them as citizens and enriching
them in an interior way has completely
disappeared from the education system
and that when you even when when when
educators refer to students they don't
refer to them as future citizens unless
they're talking about digital citizens
which is a whole other thing but instead
I talked about them as future consumers
future workers and that it's looked at
in that respect from purely economic
terms that's why I teach in prison where
people come in from different countries
not only countries but economical
conditions and if I if I can give you a
slight hint positive towards humanism
and books and reading and all this stuff
and classic I can tell tell you that I
started again to believe in literature a
lot teaching there because - these guys
coming from around the world and some of
them almost littered and others
cultivated and learned and credible
oppression in prison in prison and I
taught and I teach to them for instance
Dante Alighieri and it works and it's
perfectly comprehensible even if it's
written in middle age
Italian language and especially the
affair no affair no obviously for many
reasons that they would like to know
which circles they
well they would but it's approved at
classic not only danta but Homer or
ancient Greek erotic poets can be read
very very easily understood and liked so
it means that there is something
objective in literature in art can be
transmitted everywhere to anybody and
that's a great strength and this is the
proof I mean the the basic proof that we
are working on something that deserve to
be not defended because I don't like to
defend culture either culture defend
itself or it's not fact the culture
you